celebs are spreading a message of love
this Thanksgiving in a place where your
family can enjoy being together and
spending time together Josh Duggar
reunited with his wife Anna their
children and his 19 Kids and Counting
family for a holiday getaway in the
Ozark Mountains the Duggars shared
candid shots from their cozy cabin on
Facebook showing formerly estranged Josh
seated on the floor next to his sister
joy Anna and wife
check out Josh and Anna's baby girl
Meredith adorably hanging out with her
aunt and uncle and here's Jessa barefoot
pregnant and all smiles as she rubs her
growing belly mom Michelle Duggar wrote
as I look around the room I'm so deeply
touched by God's love his forgiveness
his kindness his provision his mercies
and his tenderness toward each of us
Mariah Carey and ex Nick Cannon came
together to celebrate Thanksgiving with
their twins Moroccan and Monroe in
Hawaii the friendly exes appear to be in
good spirits
amid Mimi's recent split from James
Packer and cannons Bob shell baby news
the only thing that's important to me is
my children you know and I want I want
what's best for them and you know I
believe my ex feels the exact same way
before the holiday feast the pop diva
stepped out in full glam to grab
groceries with her cleavage on full
display hashtag to diva meanwhile
Madonna spent Thursday giving back to
the homeless LGBT youth at a New York
City shelter she instagrammed this sweet
group shot caption because everyone
deserves to be loved and everyone
deserves a home
you